hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the first
issues that Thomas Aquinas
understandably enough engages with in
his summit a low GI is the existence of
God and there's a question whether you
can actually prove or demonstrate in
some way through argument that God
exists because if you don't actually
have God as you might say sort of
starting point then you could ask well
what are we actually doing in theology
so you can quite understand why he would
begin with this this topic and as usual
Thomas subdivides the issue into several
different parts and the first issue this
first sub issue that he considers is
whether it's self-evident that there is
a God or in Latin Woodrum Deum si sit
Peter say NOTAM and whether God exists
is with Rome damn si literally whether
God has being or not and then he brings
in this location Peter say NOTAM so we
should talk about that a little bit
before we get into it what does it mean
to be Paris they note him you could say
intuitively evident or self-evident
or in some way obvious as soon as you
think about it you realize that it has
to be the case literally it means known
through itself right known on its own
account and the way Thomas always sets
up his reasoning about this he considers
some possible what he calls objections
right let's do the whole thing again
alright try this from the start one of
the key issues that Thomas Aquinas
considers early on in his summit a
loogie I the first part of it is whether
God exists or not makes perfect sense
because you know if you don't have a God
how are you gonna have any theology
theology is about God Theo's so he's
trying to see whether we can provide
some sort of argument or grounds or
justification for holding that God
exists can we provide something like a
demonstration and some people might say
you don't even need to do that because
it's just obvious that God exists or as
he's going to say here Peter say nota
often translate it as self-evident
literally grasped or known through
itself or on its own grounds we could
say into it intuitively obvious if we
have in mind not just some sort of vague
sense of intuition but something like
you know once we understand what we're
dealing with we just see that it is that
way
and as always Thomas has this
dialectical way of going about things
he's going to consider some people
advancing the position and then he's
going to consider some other objections
to that and he'll work out his own
stance in in the process so first let's
think about what it means to be
self-evident he says somebody might say
it's it's self-evident that there is a
God why things are said to be
self-evident
to us when we are innately aware of them
and the Latin for that is when we their
cognate Co not to rally theater in s20
knowledge or understanding or mental
grasp of it naturally is in us is in the
human being is there not all human
beings and so some people would say you
know there there's there's an idea of
God and it's just implanted within all
of us it's part of our original
programming if you like or it's part of
our original endowment and then you know
another way of understanding this per se
note being you know intuitively obvious
or self-evident is that it would be
known immediately when the terms are
grasped and so he gives you some
examples of propositions like this you
know these they're first principles of
demonstration like he says when we know
that holes and parts are or exists we
know at once that holes are always
bigger than their parts that the whole
is greater than the parts not
necessarily greater than the sum of the
parts right but it's greater than any
one of the parts so he considers whether
God exists Davos si could in fact be
self-evident in these ways one of the
ways he's going to do that is by
considering something that looks very
similar to Anselm's argument in the
Proust loggia and we'll come back to
that in just a moment let's take the
other way of doing it first so he says
that John damask scene says that when
beginning his book the awareness that
God exists is implanted by nature and
everybody there for God's existence is
self-evident to all of us and he says
well that's kind of a problem
the said contra in this the on the other
hand says if it really is impossible for
us not to know this then then why is
there the fool who could say in his
heart there is no God that would seem to
be an issue and then when he's
considering this particular
line of reasoning in his response to the
objection he says the awareness that God
exists is not implanted by us in nature
and here's the key term in any clear or
specific way he says man is by nature
aware of what by nature he desires he
desires a happiness which is only to be
found in God but this is not strictly
speaking awareness that there is a God
any more than to be aware of somebody
approaching is to be aware of Peter even
if it's Peter approaching why does he
say this he says well a lot of people
have gotten very confused about what our
final end or goal or you know happiness
would be people have placed it in all
sorts of other things and Thomas will
consider this in question two of the the
next part of the soma and as well so
that's that's a problem and you know not
everybody understands the same thing by
whatever it is it's primally implanted
in us so that's not going to work he
also considers this and cell mian we
might call it Anselm Ian light argument
here which does use some of the
formulations that we do find in st.
Anselm SPRO slow Gian but isn't putting
out the entire argument and is sort of
stripping it out of its its context so
how does this one go he says that this
is you know understanding how you know
language once we understand it what it
means what the terms mean we can see
what those terms then have to signify
what relations they have to each other
what implications they have and we would
be able to see that God is per se nota
so the argument that he gives first is
that God the word God means that than
which nothing greater can be met
and interestingly as to maybe a little
bit of trivia but I think it actually
has some importance he uses the term
significado not Kogi tottery in
presenting this and tell me an argument
Anselm doesn't actually use that term of
meaning or signifying right but he says
this is what God is understood to be and
then he says consequently since
existence in thought in in intellect -
and existence in reality or in fact in
ray is greater than existence and
thought alone and since once we
understand the word God he exists and
thought he must also exist in fact and
that's you know that's a reconstruction
of an Psalms argument Thomas says well
that's not really gonna work why isn't
it going to work he gives us the the
answer in his response to number two he
says well first of all not everybody
who's hearing the word God automatically
understands it to mean that Dan which
nothing greater can be thought and there
he actually does say call Maya's Kogi
tottery known potest
which is an Tom's formula so that's
quite true not everybody understands God
to be that than which nothing greater
can be thought how do we know that's the
case well because people have thought
all sorts of crazy notions about God
like God is the body and you can think
of something greater than a body like a
spirit right so people have had all
sorts of wrongheaded notions you can't
just invoke you know cool Maya's kooky
thunder you know in potest and everyone
boom there's God all right that's not
going to work then he also attacks
another part of the argument this
juncture between existence in thought or
existence in the understanding essa in
intellect to an existence in reality in
gray he says even if the meaning of the
word God were generally recognized to be
that than which nothing greater can be
thought nothing that is defined like
that
nothing that's signified like that would
thereby be granted existence in ray in
reality or in the world of fact as it's
translated here in the Blackfriars but
merely is being thought so he is denying
that Anselm's argument actually works he
says it gets you a god that is greater
than anything else or a God that that
then which nothing greater can be
thought in thought but that does not
translate into actual existence in
reality it just means you've thought of
something like that
there's no way to get from the idea to
something corresponding to that idea in
reality so that's the consideration of
that and then a third one that's a bit
more promising at least at first he says
people could say that
listen it's self-evident that truth
exists because even in denying it you
have to admit it what do they mean by
that if you want to say there is no
truth or you know truth does not exist
you can ask the question which by the
way Anselm doesn't on truth but is that
a true statement that you're making
right now so it's it's automatically the
case that at least there's something
that is true right and now here's where
the the argument gets a little bit shaky
people say now God is truth itself
because God says I am the way the truth
and the life
so if that if truth existing is
self-evident since God is truth God
existing is self-evident and Thomas
again takes a very careful position on
this he says sure I'll grant you that
it's self-evident that truth exists in
general he says in communy right in in
some sense in the world but that doesn't
actually tell us that there's a first
truth a primavera tantum it doesn't tell
us that that's the case so you can't use
that to sort of bootstrap yourself
to god existing necessarily thomas is
going to provide us with a very
important and useful distinction when it
comes to these things that are pierce a
nota or a self-evident strictly speaking
he thinks that God's existence is
piercing no time but it's not Paris a
nota it's not self-evident to us why
well the way that Thomas understands
things being pierced a nota
is that if you have a proposition you
have a subject of a proposition and a
predicate of the proposition right the
subject is what you're talking about the
predicate is what you are saying about
that so he tells us here that for a
proposition is self-evident when the
predicate forms part of what the subject
means so what's an example of that man
is an animal why being an animal is part
of the meaning of man or human being can
you say that about Deus God and esse or
asked exists as being is the predicate
in some way contained within the subject
Thomas says yes in fact it is and he
goes on and says the proposition God
exists is self evidence in itself for as
we shall see later its subject and
predicate are actually identical because
God is his own existence or being but
there is a problem we don't actually
know what or fully know what God is we
have a dim grasp of God but we don't
really know God in itself or in himself
or whatever God happens to be we know
God is a cause primarily through the
effects of that cause so they use F they
are God exist
does not pierce a note to us it could be
however pierce a note to the wise or the
knowledgeable the people that he talks
about as sap ents those who have have
wisdom those who actually know what God
is now you could say well they're not
actually in need of a proof you're right
if they actually know what God is they
don't need it proven to them and so
Thomas would say here that we can't rely
on something like an Anselmi and proof
or these other arguments and we
certainly can't appeal to some general
sense that God just has this idea
implanted within us if we're going to
argue that God exists we have to provide
some other kind of argument and that's
what he will do but he's provided us
with some conceptual clarification here
about what it would mean to say that
God's existence or God's being is
self-evident or pierce a nota
you